let's talk about spiders i'm ash
crossing back to recap the mandalorian
chapter 10
the passenger the second episode of
season
two spoilers incoming let's get to it
[Music]
so this is one of those uh we got
ourselves into a little bit of a
kerfuffle episode but
it's also one of the most terrifying
episodes of star wars i've ever
seen this is not an episode of star wars
this is a horror film so let's recap the
passenger kicks off with
what else someone's trying to steal baby
oda and i actually thought at first that
this was like
a continuation of the last episode and i
thought that we were gonna get baby yoda
trying to trap mando and get his armor
back and we're gonna see maybe like a
big kind of
showdown but no they're just trying to
steal the baby so they closed line mando
which is a tactic we've seen the um
the murder bears use in return of the
jedi
and one of the guys nabs baby yoda and
mando's like no i'll give you anything i
have so much valuable stuff
and he's like i'll take that shiny new
jet pack
if they're trying to get the child they
probably know he's like a pretty high
bounty so i'm
interested why the jet pack was so
appealing to this guy but i digress he
gets the jet pack and i'm like no
his jet pack
he just shoots him into the sky
it just murders him i screamed it was so
funny so we go back to amy sedaris and
she's getting a lot of air time in this
show
and she's playing sebastobach with dr
mandible this giant ant he has a phd
i also appreciate that ant-man director
peyton breed directed this episode and
um
apparently can't escape giant ants so
there you go there's also a galaxy's
edge
reference easter egg in this moment
because while they're talking they go
outside and there's meat
being roasted cooked by a pod racer
engine which is a tactic we see in batu
at ronto roaster so it's being served
ronto roaster's
style but anyway mando's still on his
quest for more manos and dr mandible
and amy sedaris's character whose name
is escaping me at this moment are like
we have an idea we have this adorable
frog lady
and she needs to get back to her husband
in order to save her species but she
can't use hyperdrive because
it'll wipe out all her eggs
unfortunately for this frog lady
the hyperdrive was not going to be the
only thing that was going to take out
her eggs because baby yoda apparently
finds them
delicious and eats like i don't know
half of them
do we think mando is beating baby yoda
enough
we're concerned about that so the frog
lady amanda they can't understand each
other and at one point the frog lady
did she ever get a name i don't know i
don't think she did she cleverly uses
the
this protocol droid to communicate with
mando and this protocol droid is
zero who was part of the crew from
season one
episode 6 the prisoner and is voiced by
richard ayotte who returned to
provide the voice so these two x-wing
pilots roll up and it's captain carson
tiva
played by paul seung-young lee who you
might recognize from kim's convenience
and then trapper wolf who we've seen
before played by dave filoni
sidenote they say something here that
i've always wanted to see in star wars
so i went to catholic school
and anyone who's like been to the
catholic church i think maybe some other
churches do this too
when you say peace be with you you
automatically respond
and also with you so when anytime
someone says may the force be with you
to me i
feel it in my soul that i'm supposed to
say
and also with you and they did it so now
this is like a response to may the force
be with you
we're allowed to say it now it's a thing
now we can say it
i don't think they said that before in
star wars correct me if i'm wrong but i
don't think i've heard this before so
the x-men pilots are like we need your
beacon and
all your info and mando's like i didn't
i didn't come up with a lie for this so
he
dips and i mean literally he dips
it's into some kind of snowy ice planet
and it's not going great at all and the
frog lady's like
i'm gonna go to the spa while you sort
this out so
see you later which mood so amanda goes
after her
and baby yoda is like i'm starving to
death apparently and he's like i gotta
eat all the eggs
and so he turns around he finds more
eggs and this one's like some kind of
gross spider and at this point we're
getting like alien vibes
but we're about to get harry potter
vibes and then we're about to get
arachnophobia vibes
holy skin crawly this was
so uneasy and freaky and great and
it's just a lot for like six o'clock in
the morning
so these giant spiders pop up ew and i
believe
they're krikna which we've seen in star
wars rebels but to go way way back
concept artist ralph mcquarrie actually
drew one of these up for
empire strikes back but anyway they're
in a bit of a
bind with these giant spiders trying to
attack them
and there's little ones and then bigger
ones and the bigger ones and the bigger
ones and then there's big giant ones
you're not getting anywhere and then who
comes back who helps
the x-wing pilots because they're like
we've been good guys
this whole time and we looked up some
information about you and like you know
what you're you're a stand-up guy but
this is the most you're getting out of
us see you later
and they take off and at this point i
think the razer crest was a great
ship we loved it it did its job it got
mando and baby yoda all over the map
but at this point burn that ship to
the ground burn it burn it burn it all
burn it burn it burn it off burn it even
if there's a
sliver of cobweb on that ship
burn it burn it burn it all burn it i'm
gonna say it again
i'm gonna say it again burn it
that's my final thought burn that ship
burn that ship what did you all think of
this episode i thought it was really
fitting that peyton reed got the bug
episode he did a great job with it fun
freaky little romp but let me know what
you thought think think
thought in the comments below or you can
tweet me and if you like these little
recaps i'll keep doing them
send me a tweet let me know what you
think if you don't like them don't tell
me i'm
sensitive i'll see you next week bye